Problem number 15, and we
have two triangles.
So let's see, we have one
triangle here, one
triangle like this.
We have another triangle that
looks fairly similar.
I don't know if they actually
are similar.
I haven't read the
problem yet.
At least in the drawing, they've
drawn them to look
fairly similar.
Then they tell us that
this is triangle ABC.
This is triangle DEF.
We know that this is 8.
This is 5.
This is x degrees.
This is also x degrees.
This is 5.
Then they tell us that this
is y degrees, and
that this is y degrees.
Now let's read the problem.
If y is equal to 60 in triangle
DEF above, how much
greater is the perimeter of ABC
than the perimeter of DEF?
So y is equal to 60, right?
So what is this angle up here?
Well if we know that these two
are the base angles-- well
actually, we know 60, 60.
So what's this top angle
going to be?
Well this is an equilateral
triangle, right?
This also has to
be equal to 60.
My brain's malfunctioning.
So if all the angles are the
same, then all the sides are
the same as well, right?
It's 5 and 5.
That's an equilateral
triangle.
Then the perimeter is 5
plus 5 plus 5, is 15.
This problem, we don't know the
x angles, but we know that
they're equal.
So if these two base angles
are equal-- we know from
geometry class that,
of course-- the
sides are also equal.
So if this side is 8,
this side is also 8.
So the perimeter here is what?
8 plus 8 is 16 plus 5 is 21.
They want to know how much
greater is the perimeter of
this triangle than
this triangle?
So 21 minus 15 is 6.
That is choice C.
Next problem.
Right?
Yeah, choice C.
Problem number 16, if x and y
are positive, consecutive, odd
integers where y is greater than
x, which of the following
is equal to y squared
minus x squared?
So x and y are positive,
consecutive, odd integers, and
y is greater than x.
So that means that y is
equal to x plus what?
It's equal to x plus 2.
If they were consecutive just
integers, then y would be
equal to x plus 1.
It would be 1 more than x.
But since we know that they're
both odd, and y is the next
larger odd number-- the
difference between any two odd
numbers is 2-- so y is going
to be 2 more than x.
If x is 5, then y is 7.
Consecutive, odd integers,
if x is 3, y is 5.
y is 2 more than x.
So we know y is equal
to x plus 2.
So they want us to kind of
rewrite this expression.
Well we know from algebra class
we can factor this as y
plus x times y minus x, right?
Then what is y plus x?
Actually, we don't even
have to do this.
We don't even have
to factor it.
We know what y is
equal to, right?
y is equal to x plus 2.
So that is equal to x plus 2
squared minus x squared.
This is equal to-- we just
multiply it out-- x squared
plus 4x plus 4.
That's this term.
Now we minus x squared.
So this cancels out with this,
and we're left with 4x plus 4,
which is choice E.
Whenever I see something like
this, my first temptation is
to factor it out.
You could have done it, and
then you could have
substituted it back in.
But you didn't even
have to do that.
Image: clear image,
invert colors.
It's actually 6:30 in the
morning after Thanksgiving.
You've got to appreciate
my discipline.
All right, problem number 17.
My wife's actually a medical
resident and she had to work
36 hours yesterday.
Then she came home, essentially
passed out, missed
Thanksgiving, everything,
and then she just
went to work again.
She has like a 12-hour
shift, it's crazy.
She only has a year left and
I look forward to that.
But there might be fewer
math videos once I
have my wife back.
But anyway, back to Math.
Problem number 17, in the xy
plane, line l passes through
the origin and is perpendicular
to the line.
So l is perpendicular to the
line 4x plus y is equal to k,
and l passes through the origin,
through 0, 0-- that's
the origin-- where
k is a constant.
If the two lines intersect at
the point t, t plus 1, what is
the value of t?
So first of all, we
know this line is
perpendicular to this line.
So what does perpendicular
tell us?
Perpendicular says whatever the
slope was of this line,
the slope of this line would
be the negative inverse.
So let's figure out what the
slope of this line is.
So we know that 4x plus
y is equal to k.
So y is equal to minus
4x plus k.
Now this is kind of familiar,
y equals mx plus b format.
So the slope of this
line is minus 4.
The slope equals minus 4.
So the slope of this
line is minus 4.
So what is the slope of l?
Well l is perpendicular
to this line.
So we know that l is going to
have the negative inverse of
this slope.
So the negative inverse of minus
4 is-- well it'll become
positive, and you take
the inverse.
The slope of l is 1/4.
We also know that l goes
through the origin.
So its y-intercept is 0.
So we know the equation of l.
We know that the equation of
l is y is equal to 1/4 x.
We know there's no plus b,
because it goes through 0, 0.
If you didn't believe me, you
can put 0, 0 in here and then
solve for b.
You'll get 0 equals 0 plus b.
So b is 0.
But anyway, so this is l.
We've solved for the
equation for l.
Now they tell us that
we intersect--
where was the problem?
I lost track of the page--
we intersect at the
point t, t plus 1.
They want to figure
out what t is.
So when x is t, y is t plus 1.
So let's see, so y is
t plus 1, so t plus
1 is equal to 1/4.
Then, x is t.
I just substituted t and
t plus 1 for x and y.
Now we just solve.
Let's see, if we subtract 1/4
t from both sides-- let me
finish this problem up
here-- we subtract
1/4 t from both sides.
We get 3/4 t plus
1 is equal to 0.
I just subtracted 1/4
t from this 1t.
So you get 3/4 t.
Subtract 1 from both sides,
you get 3/4 t is
equal to minus 1.
Then you just multiply both
sides times the inverse, 4/3.
So t-- this cancels out,
of course-- t is
equal to minus 4/3.
What is my choice there?
Oh, there I go.
Choice number A.
I got scared.
I looked at the wrong problem,
I didn't see my choice.
I thought maybe I
did it wrong.
Choice number A.
And I will do problem 18
in the next video.
I'll see you soon.